[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta que en esta ocasión nos
lleva a senegal país que hace 20 años
vivió una tragedia más mortal que la del
Titanic hablamos de un naufragio
Terrible y aún desconocido el Yola es el
nombre del ferry que zarpó el 26 de
septiembre de 2002 en un viaje de 17
horas desde el sur de senegal con
destino a la capital Dakar en mitad de
la noche a 40 kilómetros de la costa
mientras caían lluvias tropicales y
soplaban fuertes vientos la embarcación
volcó los servicios de rescate tardaron
más de 16 horas en llegar al lugar y
solo 64 pasajeros sobrevivieron a esa
noche infernal hubo múltiples causas que
desencadenaron la catástrofe el Yola
gestionado por la marina senegalesa
estaba en malas condiciones estaba
sobrecargado con cuatro veces más
pasajeros que el máximo permitido las
familias de las víctimas intentaron
llegar al fondo de aquella terrible la
noche y algunas incluso presentaron una
denuncia contra el estado senegalés por
negligencia pero el caso se cerró en
senegal tan solo un año después de que
ocurrieran los hechos y hasta el día de
hoy nadie les ha rendido cuentas dos
décadas después las familias de las
víctimas siguen exigiendo justicia y
luchan para que la catástrofe del Yola
no quede en el olvido veamos este
reportaje de Sara sacó para Franz 24
[Música]
la capital de casamanche en el sur del
país
de las 1863 muertes oficiales en el Yola
casimilson de la ciudad la tragedia ha
dejado una profunda huella en la ciudad
sin embargo los lugares de memoria son
escasos
este cementerio tiene unas 40 tumbas la
mayoría anónimas el idiota nunca sabrá
si uno de ellos contienen los restos de
su hermano
yo mismo no tengo una tumba a la que ir
no sé pero me encuentro otra vez de esta
tumba que tengo delante y de las otras
que simbolizan el hundimiento del guión
la gran mayoría de las víctimas de la
yolá nunca han encontrado los restos de
sus seres queridos al día siguiente del
hundimiento solo se recuperaron 450
cuerpos los demás desaparecieron
hundidos siempre con el barco
Mari Joseph también viene regularmente a
visitar estas tumbas desconocidas
tampoco encontró el cuerpo de su hija
tampoco hizo su Duelo
me hubieran dicho que habían encontrado
el cuerpo de mi hija no vi la cara de mi
hija
con los restos Sería mucho más fácil
porque habríamos respetado el proceso
que nos habría llevado al cementerio
pero en el cuerpo
no es posible
el Duelo es imposible sin el cuerpo
a pesar de las promesas de los sucesivos
gobiernos lo que queda de la Yola nunca
se ha recuperado del fondo del mar la
demanda de las familias de las víctimas
es la misma desde hace 20 años
el barco está en el agua tiene los
medios para recuperarlo pero no sabemos
por qué no quieren hacerlo
desde que el barco se hundió hemos
estado gritando hasta el día de hoy
seguimos gritando pero nuestras
autoridades nunca responden al llamado
estamos enfadados con ellos
lo que podría aliviarnos a nosotros y a
las víctimas que siguen en el fondo del
océano y que no dejan de pedirnos que
vengamos a sacarlas del agua
es proceder al rescate y al mismo tiempo
permitir a las familias hacer el Duelo
Es decir liberarse;
[Música]
para los familiares de las víctimas el
tiempo se detuvo el 26 de septiembre de
2002 ese día el Yola salió del puerto de
Sign Shore sobrecargado inclinado hacia
un lado poco antes de la medianoche en
medio de una tormenta volcó frente a la
costa de gambia 20 años después para Los
afectados la tragedia sigue siendo una
herida abierta
volvemos a encontrarnos con Mary josef
esta vez en el mercado del pescado de
Sign short madre soltera crió sola a sus
cinco hijos con la ayuda de su pequeño
negocio
hasta la maleta
Este es mi lugar
cuando un negocio mi pescado
lo dispongo lo vendo aquí hace 20 años
su hija françois una brillante
estudiante desapareció en el ferry
llevándose las esperanzas de su madre
cayó en ese accidente la de 21 años
durante su segundo año en la ciudad de
dakarche anta dior
Ah tenía la esperanza de que tal vez
fuera ella la que Dios me había enviado
para secar mis lágrimas algún día
porque a mi edad Como ven normalmente no
debería estar aquí
porque sé quién era mi hija
Estaba dispuesta a hacer cualquier cosa
por mí hoy no me habría dejado en ese
mercado y aquí estoy ahora estoy aquí de
por vida al igual que las familias de
las víctimas que lo solicitaron Mari
josep fue indemnizada por el estado hace
unos años recibió 10 millones de francos
cfa algo más de 15.000 euros 20 años
después a la pena se suma la amargura la
sensación de una vida desperdiciada
dieron 10 millones que son 10 millones
por 20 años
usted la madre o el padre no ha visto el
cuerpo de su hijo en que se convertirá
ser una persona medio loca
si existe eso será medio loco tendrá un
traumatismo en la cabeza en el cerebro
así es
[Música]
un barrio obrero de
Allí es donde siempre ha vivido el
idiota este hombre de 54 años es miembro
activo de la asociación Nacional de
familiares de las víctimas de la yolá
Esa es mi hija jugando ahí
todo bien el drama cambió su vida
durante Las dos últimas décadas este
académico ha dedicado su tiempo a la
memoria del naufragio
estamos en la casa de la familia aquí
esta casa se construyó antes de que yo
naciera así que ha durado mucho tiempo
y vivimos aquí
en la casa sigue rondando la sombra de
Michelle el hermano mayor desaparecido
se ha quedado aquí desde que dejó San
Luis
después de dejar la selección volvió y
esta era su habitación
el día de la tragedia Michelle antiguo
profesional del fútbol sale de la casa
con los 26 niños de su escuela de fútbol
y en fila India salieron los niños pero
era muy bonito los veías en fila India
saliendo de la casa luego pasando por el
otro lado hacia el puerto con su equipo
sus bolsas colgadas al hombro y demás y
el día siguiente nos enteramos de la
catástrofe
un informe de investigación realizado en
2002 puso de manifiesto graves
deficiencias y negligencias a todos los
niveles en el mantenimiento y la gestión
de este buque que entonces era operado
por la armada nacional sin embargo los
tribunales desestimaron el caso al año
siguiente El capitán que murió en el
naufragio es considerado el único
responsable la ira de Lidia atta contra
las autoridades de su país no cesa
el barco no estaba capacitado para
navegar desde Shore
desde el punto de vista de su
construcción
en qué lado no funcionaba los balastros
no estaban operando solo había un motor
en lugar de llevar 4 550 personas
llevaron 2000
eso es lo realmente inquietante Así que
no es posible que hoy nos digan que no
hay ningún responsable Esto no es
posible los responsables del yolá están
en todas partes
instituciones ministros de la República
y otros
Así que simplemente pedimos que la ley
actúe nos encontramos con el idiota de
Camino hacia un quesil un pueblo de la
región donde vive uno de los
sobrevivientes de Yola
[Música]
actualmente el Yola nos ha reconstituido
todos somos una familia así que lo
sobrevivientes significan mucho para
nosotros
lleva tenía 34 años en el momento del
naufragio es uno de los 64
sobrevivientes de yula donde los muertos
fueron casi 2.000 este profesor cultiva
su huerto en su tiempo libre
es un amigo desde hace mucho tiempo
hemos sufrido al mismo tiempo puedo
decir que fue el Yola el que nos unió sé
que es muy complicado para ellos que
realmente han vivido este naufragio y
que no han tenido un acompañamiento que
les permita superar
esta experiencia traumática
porque eucenua ha recorrido un largo
camino en el momento de la tragedia El
joven comerciante lleno de planes
viajaba de ida y vuelta a Dakar
unas 15 personas de su pueblo subieron
al barco ese día sus amigos y su propio
hermano nunca volvieron
tenía miedo de las preguntas porque todo
el mundo vendría a preguntarme qué pasa
con mi hijo Qué pasa con mi hijo ve la
familia que está aquí son vecinos
directos que han perdido a su hijo mayor
así que vendrían a preguntarme y el otro
lo has visto cómo ocurrió así que para
evitar todo esto preferí vivir en la
clandestinidad vivir como un
sobreviviente no es algo fácil es
difícil hoy es capaz de poner palabras a
La pesadilla que vivió
el 26 de septiembre de 2002 unos minutos
antes de la medianoche El joven se
encontraba en el gran comedor del ferry
era una multitud
era muchos y el agua se los tragos en el
restaurante donde se cortó la luz
[Música]
nos veía a morir juntos
y gritaban hasta perder la voz
esta imagen me acompaña siempre
después son dos personas distintas
escapa del interior del barco por un ojo
de buey
resiste 7 largas horas en aguas heladas
fui algo blanco que venía hacia mí
agarré la cosa era un chaleco
y cuando traté de sostenerlo contra mí
sentí que había una persona adentro
había intentado ponerse el chaleco pero
desgraciadamente estaba mal sujeto y se
ahogó
Así que lo cogí y lo enrolle Bien y fue
Entonces cuando empecé a dormir dormía
tranquilamente como si estuviera en una
cama porque estaba agotado exhausto
tras años de insomnio y traumas usenú ha
vuelto a llevar una vida casi normal y
comenzó una familia sin embargo todavía
lleva las cicatrices de naufragio
cuando oigo ruido me asusto
es por las botellas en el restaurante
Las mesas y los gritos de ese día antes
de la separación
que siempre se quedaron allí nunca
perdonaré
hay que hacer justicia que la gente sea
condenada juzgada y sentenciada por su
acto criminal
el naufragio también dejó 1900 huérfanos
una ley prevé su cobertura financiera
por parte del Estado en realidad menos
de la mitad de los niños están bajo la
tutela de la nación al menos otros 200
según la cifra oficial siguen esperando
la regularización hoy los huérfanos de
julá son adultos a bubacar solo tenía 6
años cuando perdió a su madre y a su
hermana pequeña en el naufragio
si no estoy en la universidad ayuda a mi
padre en la tienda
[Música]
desde que era un niño él me crió desde
que mi madre partió
al igual que abuba Card Amy y jampate
han perdido a uno de sus padres los tres
están bajo la tutela de la nación y han
estado Bajo su cuidado durante años hoy
como adultos se sienten abandonados
si me dieran toda la fortuna del mundo y
me dieran la oportunidad de ver a mi
madre aunque fuera un día elegiría
volver a verla porque crecí sin amor
materno
Así que el estado no puede arreglarlo
pero sí puede mitigar el daño dándonos
algún trabajo para que podamos ayudar a
nuestros padres
ha visto a mi padre ha envejecido
necesita que sus hijos le ayuden
nacional su deseo ser contratado por el
estado por ejemplo en el futuro
monumento ayola un monumento en
construcción a lo largo del Río en el
mismo lugar donde el ferry partió hace
20 años esta fue una de las primeras
exigencias de las familias de las
víctimas al día siguiente de la tragedia
pidieron al Estado este símbolo como
homenaje a sus muertos el idiota no se
cansa de visitar el sitio
es una gran alegría para las familias de
las víctimas ver esta edificación
erigirse se espera que el monumento se
entregue a finales de año albergará un
museo dedicado al naufragio Karim sania
trabaja como guardia de seguridad en la
obra perdió a su mujer y a sus tres
hijos en la Yola En ningún lugar de las
tumbas de las fosas comunes están
inscritos los nombres de mi mujer y de
mis hijos por lo que no he visto ni
tumbas ni cuerpos construir este
monumento es como Construir la tumba de
mi familia Así es como yo lo veo
Así que cuando estoy aquí todos los días
creo que estoy haciendo algo por mi
familia que se ha ido porque no hice mi
Duelo permitirá a todas las generaciones
futuras conocer lo que ocurrió en
senegal la noche del 26 de septiembre de
un lugar contra el olvido para que una
tragedia así no vuelva a ocurrir
incluso la construcción del monumento es
un contra silencio puede decir que es un
lugar de Renacimiento para la familias
un lugar de paso de la muerte a la vida
un motivo de satisfacción para los
familiares de los desaparecidos los tres
barcos que operan entre Dakar y siguen
Shore cumplen ahora con las normas y
estándares internacionales También
tienen una esperanza que el futuro
Memorial albergue Algún día lo que queda
del joular su reliquias rescatar los
restos del naufragio sigue siendo su
principal petición para ellos el único
camino hacia la paz
esto es todo por la edición de boleto de
vuelta de esta semana que nos llevó a
senegal 20 años después del naufragio
del Yola si quiere ver este y otros
episodios puede visitar nuestra página
web France 24.com Hasta pronto